hey listen man it's an honor to be here
nice to be able to be above the ranks of
such in the podcast well I'll send this
you don't find yeah we image what we've
gone through the woods - yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] right hey everybody welcome to
another episode of tip and Tyson I mean
hot boxin I'm Evan Britain and I might
die that money we got the man in here
was handy I took the tipster rolling
right out and expeditiously yeah your
new podcast yeah stoked man it was a it
was a pleasure to have a mic on the head
I know I mean now we got to get you on
hey man I'll come on there but you gotta
have mic on you gotta let him just roll
hey what I wanted to say to you early
there dump I'm totally I mean you look
like you just got it all man it's a pity
you've got the way you conduct you so I
don't know why what's happened behind
the campbellot you've got all the
answers man man I I think the greatest
thing I know is what I don't know cuz
you know saying I I don't have all the
answers but I can I can find oh you know
I'm saying and I have an incredible
support system my family my wife my
momma
you know her mom my mother-in-law look
like good system on television I don't
think yeah that was a bad [ __ ]
I don't think it's many [ __ ]
who can kind of like do what we do how
we do it the way you don't mean good you
know we had just enough fun you know
what I'm saying to not [ __ ] it up
and we always um we were always sad when
we were hearing stories and remember you
and your wife not getting along we
didn't get along for me family show if
they're together regardless of what yeah
I mean that's what I always say man you
know the key to the key to being
together for 30 years 30 40 50 years the
key this is the secret I have a bad
memory don't [ __ ] leave you got to do
is not [ __ ] leave you know but I mean
I love I love my family I love my old
lady I think and I love our our our
journey our evolution the Kevin
chemistry looks beautiful on television
yeah man we fought with each other man I
think the greatest thing is kind of weak
but when let's just say this like when
we started dating I was 20 21 years old
so even just to be able to keep a woman
at 21 in your 20s little own for me that
was so I was too selfish yeah I'm a
selfish person I do think about me wait
I think that you know the thing is I've
always been invested into her happiness
you dig like it always made me feel good
to make her head
so yeah yeah tip man how'd you get into
podcasting well my manager asked me to
go to a meeting my marriage of bran
share asked me to go to a meeting to
some other white people right yeah
there's money for you I didn't know huh
Brian makes money for and makes money
for me and also even more so to make
money he's a brother and friend of mine
and you know I'm saying partnering in my
television business book I'm Ryan
yeah Brian rocks rocks so he so he
actually asked me to go to a meeting
with some Jewish fellows that I didn't
know but I was happy to go he knows
their Peter and Neil from rock just one
and I sat down and you know and listen
Brian into me and he said hey listen
listen okay I know it's not really what
you got on you your life goal but just
hear him out the great guys just hear
him out that's right cool so he sat down
they say tip I was you have a podcast
know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna doing a
podcast
oh no man you know it's the future man
and then it was like well you know what
your presence on social media and and
and and you know your opinions being so
somewhat provocative they provide for an
audience who would like to hear you
expound upon your perspective yeah and I
just thought of like hmm yeah I have a
podcast yeah and I just started to think
about how we would kind of put it
together and and expeditiously was born
from that though well your flow is so
expeditious hey that's a that's a great
way to describe how you wrap yeah I love
them wrap i watch you wrap every day
when I give them my treadmill and
workout on Noah so no song you on your
numb one love with game yeah everybody's
wrapping the remix I don't remember the
video out there or everybody Jones
everybody's wrap yeah
that's dope man and I think that you
know you have such a great way of
relating to people like for instance you
guys had Alex Jones on yeah [ __ ] Alex
tell me no I really I think that's
[ __ ] bad-ass of you to bring on
somebody who's so the polar opposite
sure you know relax
yeah story Alex Jones talk about him
what was that like I mean he was just
you know a guy with some alternative
ideas like what you know just secret
societies secret meetings sacrificing
children just all kinds of [ __ ] man yeah
why wouldn't people do that I mean I'm
not saying that they didn't but I mean
he saying he's claiming to have
brokenness okay
yeah a piece of gay and all that stuff
he's claiming to have broken into and
the thing is it only is only to
implicate it only implicates Democrats
right which is kind of what
like okay I know you full of [ __ ] but
you know there may be some truth wrapped
up in it but it's gonna be just as much
that's what democracy and for the
democracy hmm yeah democracy yeah okay
that's what society is run by the demons
listen um that's your perception that
what they are right you say mean I think
they would call like in for like 2000
years ago they would call us barbarians
I mean I think barbarian it definitely
takes it definitely takes in a pretty
[ __ ] up perspective to do something to
others like you know to impose your
authority or wheel yeah in doing
something that will affect others in a
way that it won't affect you and you
just do it implicitly like you know
you're saying about cavalierly without
any concern you know like that's pretty
demanding like awesome like river [ __ ]
you show me like the Flint was by the
[ __ ] who decided to do that
that's seven that's some despicable
dastardly diabolical [ __ ] you know what
I mean there's evil exactly is of is of
the demon so I think you monkey so in a
way you must say that demons forget that
for you have the fact that people have
like when I was a young kid my hood look
like somebody hit it with a nuclear bomb
like banded bigger [ __ ] bloke I live
right next door at and um I thought I
get old I say to myself how could I go
man allow human beings to live like that
my mother than the way we live like that
well then Mike like we had in the 70s to
live like the humans are elected that
that was it a new main well then
yesterday we had Justin on yeah him goes
to the Congo and he helps these pygmy
tribes gadget and these people have been
subject to atrocities that you can't
even imagine you know in slave mentality
mutilated raped just completely
demoralized as as a culture
and Mike said yesterday what people in
other countries wouldn't give to be
homeless in America and I thought how
[ __ ] crazy that is so then you take
that to say a politician's
mindset and outlook and he's looking at
Brownsville going well what do they have
to complain about exactly I guess
exactly I mean to be honest and so they
can rationalize this [ __ ] yes it's hard
but that they would choose to
rationalize this [ __ ] because honestly
if they caught because most politicians
consider themselves Christian right okay
all right so if we go and buy as it
assigns to the Bible and the
Constitution for that matter you
supposed to work for your brother but
you won't feel sell my brother he might
get bigger than me and [ __ ] my wife I'm
not attractive we're all in cadets isn't
the animal mind
no that's we have to control those
thoughts yeah we have enemy complex yeah
yeah you know me everywhere program yeah
if I help him here take what I have I
never felt out I overcome myself feeling
that way before
oh well I don't know maybe you're a
Martian or something self-preservation
think of self you can't think about hate
you can't they hate then if you say that
say hey listen I just got my paycheck
from my gig I'm gonna give it to him no
cuz this is mine I work for it yeah I
would like to afford you the opportunity
to do the same thing for yourself as I
could do for myself well sometimes we do
that though right sometimes sometimes we
give to the people around us who need it
this is true know what I learned from my
mentor customizer was that it comes a
time in life when the most important
thing that means to you something to you
you have to give it up
mm-hmm willingly huh
you mean willingly get it up I just have
it taken from you
well ye both ways know the end of the
end of the period is that it we won't be
together again right you know the world
as you know it must be turned upside
yeah and we have to deal with that yeah
no enough have to do when I'm adapting
yeah you know that's what we've been
doing for the EON the years we've been
they've been adapting your life is a
series of adjustments from the time
you're born to the time you dad oh good
I'll make an adjustment can you think
about I wouldn't want the first Mike the
first me the first man in my bloodline
in my gene would he look at the first
one billions of years ago but the guy
they found the oldest guy 4.4 million
years I wonder who with Mike Tyson back
then what did he look like
who was the first me 4.4 billion years
or who was representing me then mm you
know who was representing me my
bloodline the man who will see what did
he look like was he white with the Asia
but there is something we've never seen
anything maybe like another species yeah
maybe who was mine who is my relative
and other species do rectals or
something like that yeah man you named
it the erectus
no that's one what's one of the first
stand-up the first one it's one of the
first stood up okay so mo erectus yeah
but there are guys one they're not the
first one did the first one that stood
up so what would they do it before they
erect crawling whoa yeah probably we get
the two feet and the whiting quicker
they were afraid they were afraid of
everything yeah everything was doctor
afraid so the erectus was in an
evolution the evolution yeah yeah yeah
anywhere crack the code I've seen the
matrix
no no job
in degree and everything times people
still have mom jeans so far back that
they grow tail they have the bone of a
tail growing out of them
hmm some people you know I mean yeah
well I mean we do all have the tailbone
job but someone longer than not yeah
yeah yeah I know someone abnormally
longer than yeah you hate you hate you
hate to catch it with a [ __ ] with a
long tail boat this is the worst thing
yeah long tail boat what do you think
about the elongated skulls Yeah right I
think they were tired I think there was
a style and that's what they did the
style show their superiority but there's
more bone matter so it's actually a
longer at all and I didn't think it had
something to do with attractiveness
definitely oh I have nothing to do with
that tract isn't it where did they see
where would they like they dig these up
all over the world yeah no I understand
that but I don't think no I'm saying
what would the idea that that was more
attractive well some African tribes did
it his brain is so big he must be a God
look any think of look any Conda in that
big brain Yeah right make my life life
heavenly maybe it's cuz they saw aliens
I think that yeah but well there there
are tribes what's the tribe in Africa
Mike were the women they didn't rings on
the Nexus Oman yeah yeah yeah that's the
same thing yeah and they can never take
those rings off they're gonna break what
yeah a specific tribe I can't think of
the name but tip where do you live
i migrated between here in atlanta nice
smell it's awesome but I learned from my
class show that it rains diamonds and
Saturday yes yes I have my phone well
again it's liquid diamonds the
atmosphere has liquid diamonds in a desk
that's consolation enough for me we're
animals and information out here you dig
it'll say
animals yes tight like a two-year-old
especially this is our Jupiter on
Jupiter and Neptune Ubuntu them up we'll
get money oh [ __ ] no wonder
[ __ ] trying to get up there
yeah so this is Neptune and Saturn I got
37 you got to bring some of these topics
on your progress
absolutely scientists believe that on
Jupiter and Saturn it rains diamonds new
atmospheric data before the gas giants
indicate that carbon is abundant and
it's dazzling crystal for lightness
don't turn methane into soot which
hardens into chunks of graph 8 and then
diamond as it falls
wow I wonder what the [ __ ] a Saturn
diamond it look like no no I think it
would be shaped different and it'd be
liquefied it might be shaped like a
raindrop I have rocks and let me ask you
this rock I wanted a break up when they
hit the surface mmm no they don't they
don't they just Hale yeah come apart of
the earth again yeah the cluster so Mike
and I asked this question frequently was
that where do your thoughts come from
huh and to to piggyback on that when
you're rapping and you're in my thoughts
my thoughts oh that [ __ ] god laughter
finally he can't explain that what do
you mean you mean what it says let me I
have him explain his experience of that
experience of creating music yeah
creating a song where they derive first
of all to rise from from my experiences
or some form of a story I'd like to tell
and that that that that experience could
be maximize my interactions with the
young lady at the club or you know my
interaction in a relationship with a
lady or it could be my experiences in
the street so you know I'm saying but it
starts there and then what which of
these stories I want to tell and then
you know of course I just make sense I
got to say some cold [ __ ]
you know I got this I got to say some
cold [ __ ] but then it all has to kind of
like surround a narrative so that's
where it started
do you write it down on paper sometimes
I doing sometimes I don't
it just depends on what kind of song I
want to make if I want to saw in the
sound effortless and just kind of like
20 folds or you know maybe even like you
don't know me like I usually the anthems
are the ones that all right there mmm
you just come out of you
yeah because usually it comes to it
comes to mind quicker than I can
actually jet it down so by the time I
try to write out write down everything
that I've already thought I could have
just laid it down on a try and by the
time I finished writing it I mean I
forgot some of it so I just get in there
and just do it sometimes but then when I
really really really get in my back and
I really want to out wrap people I put
pee in the pan mmm you know said I got
polite you know some books right you
know muff the services and philosophy
books and just you know just to pique my
interest and create thoughts you know
the ring I just throw [ __ ] in there just
because I have the time to do so but
just a lot it's a lot of effort yeah a
lot of effort it's fine you know when I
do the [ __ ] I always tell my sons when
you actually have someone's ear there I
kind of they're inviting you in and to
make their world better so how you want
to create how you want to paint the
picture to them that [ __ ] yes
huge possibility man I love that why you
don't want to rap about it so I'm glad
like I really didn't Dennis Rodman left
the building
ladies and gentlemen the legendary oh no
that's really interesting man and you
know like Mike was created by the
universe to be by God to be this fighter
and it's just his energy just radiated
being the greatest warrior on the planet
okay and with you I'm curious have you
felt that with your music like this is
just what you were born to do music
flows through your I was born in a I was
born to lead people mmm I was born to
lead people I think music was just kind
of a yes is the instrument yeah yeah
yeah but I think that is my passion
not necessarily my purpose yeah no I
definitely do so definitely I think I
was put here to lead people I love that
man
and I love that idea of when you have so
when someone gives you their ear or you
have someone's ear that responsibility
because they're letting you in to make
their world a better place yeah and I
mean I have you know that's why sometime
when I listen to the old she did don't
really sound the same to me hmm
not coming out of my mouth you know what
I'm saying they don't really sound the
same because of my because of my
evolution hmm you know and then
sometimes I'm in the mood I don't wanna
hear nothing but there and that's what I
play media gonna say here they all
represent the one thing I can say about
my albums is no matter how much
ignorance I put in it I put enough
information in there if you really
wanted it there might not have been the
most popular songs from the album but
they were there yeah and you could have
listened to and you couldn't you know
guy got observed a different perspective
if you wanted to yeah that stuff I get
that well you've got another show dude
yeah rhythm and
yeah about that tell us about that and I
was dope man it was a dope it was like a
hip hop competition show it was on
Netflix yeah me cardi B chance the
rapper man we basically combed the
streets and found what's that the next
generation she looks pretty awesome
marikar that's about little sis man she
uh I think she's she's an incredible
spirit she knows and I think she's a ver
I miss ya she's very honest and
transparent and her you know I mean yeah
so you have to appreciate that but she's
you know the probably the one of the
most sincere people you have me she was
the best part of hustlers [ __ ] did you
see the haven't seen the movie nine no
not great ain't seen not great cardi B
should have been in way more [ __ ] I miss
my two sons I take you actually for it
she lived that [ __ ] so right it's a
great story she was you know that
happened I'm a dead pig when it happened
yeah dumb [ __ ]
she got damn she was definitely one of
the highlights of the experience in
chance he has an incredible amount of
insight and a perspective looking when I
used to be in the strip club scene man
all the time when I come to the strip
club these are my friends I date them
with no to my little sons I know that
baby's daddies either the mother the
mothers I loaned them mother's money
[ __ ] this is my life [ __ ] I'm in this
you can't give me I'm in a strip club
people get me a date I might get time to
go say [ __ ] but you're mine oh they
shift then I go I'm everybody loves a
good trip to the day shift we leave the
stripper been me going over the girls
house and there's our bride there's a
whole different animal over there
[Laughter]
disrespectful by a dancer called I never
never in my life if anything's there
gonna get to utmost respect
they got tough work smile on your face
the last 20 years
nothing like creating those memories
with special people nothing like create
memories with special people enjoying
the moment this is all about right
compounding Brodie's compiling memories
that we can live that day and we old and
and then the day we're gonna be a
skeleton smiling yeah it's all the good
times right to you Benson you've done
some acting too oh yeah American
Gangster uh your first movie you not
takers he made willpower oh yeah he Paul
Walker this is so meet me here Idris
Brown Michael Ealy you know we uh you
look good too never appreciated bro
thank you but I think that's just
because you you're always 100% yourself
man is the only me I know how to be
right no one could be yeah brother can't
even beat you I mean I appreciate being
able to you know maintain such a
relevant presence and to evolve so much
as a man in front of the world I'll
counter you did what I'm saying yeah I
feel like it was you know it was like
right before the eyes of the world and I
was able to like kind of turn it around
and develop new a new perspective yeah
but you didn't let nobody dictate your
life or judge you or put you in a
position to put in a box and say this is
who you are right right I mean that's a
sign dictate who you were never can I
mean you know all we have is all we have
is us you know our our journey and our
experiences the path from how we get
from where we were to where we are at a
certain point that's our intellectual
property you know I mean that's that's
like when I ain't got a necessary I'm
finna say this story I'm gonna tell you
how I got this high ended up right here
and I don't work for anybody anybody
lives an interesting life you have to
work hard to not live an interesting
life if you you cuz you're flawed I mean
you're flawed you're gonna find yourself
in circumstances how do you respond it
of circumstances and nobody if you down
and you didn't die didn't [ __ ] ain't
nowhere else to go but up you know and
when you get up high you and compare so
by the time anybody is sixty years old
they got a whole bunch of that [ __ ] to
talk about that will be interesting to
watch 60 [ __ ] years on that far away
man just imagine the [ __ ] Mike Tyson
movie life is all about losing the baby
I think they would have but life's about
losing absolute winning next thing you
know you lost your hair inertia you lost
you dig it dig it my house there used to
be you lost that you think you lost your
ability to reason with your impatient
child you know that's what life is all
about the next thing you know you've
lost your life everything's over and
life is just about a process of law hmm
nobody wins at the end the way went so
Bill Belichick no that's just what it is
nobody really wins in fighting so hard
to win me yes yes let it go
stop fight you know it's let it go in
life and it's just gonna happen flew it
like river not stiff flight stone let it
go don't make it happen it's gonna
happen it's beautiful
how do you feel about that now half it
about what life is about loss
I mean I think that with those losses
come lessons in those yes yes yeah life
big if teacher no to deal with loss and
you know take the lessons from you
prosper yeah don't let it don't let it
define you
well that's interesting because the
losses are a lot of external things but
there's a lot of internal gain through
all of them losses all while in you know
you know because like you said you're
I'm sorry what's that thing you use now
is you take me to the bypass pill for
you can stop pissing really one thing
you gotta blow max dig up it's like him
it's good beautiful show
good stuff be expeditiously y'all with
speed and efficiency and fast of it
that's how you knock people out my
additionally yeah [ __ ] tip uses some
good words to his word good vocab he has
a son that's alike award-winning rapper
oh really
yeah well I'll talk about that woman
comes back what's this little [ __ ] um
will see iti
let me feel my incredible rate from the
other way to 20 laughs and I'm so
grateful my shoots funny
yeah it's awesome looking hot I'll be
235 yeah they're [ __ ] in the 20s you
look good man I feel good it's awesome
just a lot of walking
oh yeah I'm listening I do an hour a day
walk I would let me treadmill walking
and then do the bike you do the bike -
uh-huh
two hours a day you're doing a yoga or
anything no no I'm gonna try that one
day - I think you dig I'm a cool mode
I'm in I'm glad he's [ __ ] chilled out
and yes
meditate yeah yeah come on snow here you
go sister should we get that chair oh
okay absolutely beautiful man right Oh
family in here yeah so what did I miss
you're talking about your son rapper
yeah domani yep yeah tell us about him
am you proud of validly as a little foot
did a pilot talk about right yeah man he
um
he's 18 he just released a project
called time will tell us an incredible
project
he just incredibly evolved and matures
as an artist you did me singing his
metamorphosis inspires me you know
that's all stream the crowd of only then
again he 18 he thinks he I found my boys
my boys gave me he turned 18 he can
really be he was accepted it I think was
a yellow yell some people he wants to go
single school I have satisfied Stanford
was his major like
people who see if he wants to come
that's dope
tell them about some of what he does man
my thumb a guy 17 years old but a couple
of years ago interesting he goes to
other countries like Haiti and place in
Africa and he build bridges and down
he's one of those guys look or like
engineers both a guy like humanitarian I
tell ya he's also an engineer if he
built a bridge he was accepted at he's
[ __ ] um elite schools and stuff I'm so
proud of him so well my life I you say
why imagine if I went to Harvard a year
now this guy doing this stuff at the one
you spoke that into existence to power
the law of attraction ya know so the
[ __ ] gonna be a box the right guy
telling Berkeley when you can't do
nothing else you gotta be a fighter yeah
I'm serious
you can't do that no they be a fighting
[ __ ] I mean I think there's some truth
for that something yeah I have another
son - his name is king and I'm tellin ya
King Crazy's here but he's uh he's 15
years old he's got his learner's license
oh yeah yeah yeah he's also putting
together putting this you know he's he's
he's made evolution yeah he's made
evolution teenager yeah we working hard
man you know awesome doing it doing our
little lot of heavy the heavy lifting to
get him to it
what's he what does he like he likes
music just try to prioritize it over
school sometimes and you know that but I
I'm proud of him because he answers to
the challenge of you know making
adjustments yes I'm gonna say before we
got to do that that's what we do till we
dead and continue to adjust and adapt
yeah have to absolutely that's how you
grow fucking-a yeah do you have any
music you're working on right now I make
music every day you know to me we're
always making it I'm always making music
that's just saying you know I don't know
I just feel like you know
my time effort and energy can be so much
more useful in other areas I don't think
music calls upon all my gifts you know
it means I can do music you know but I I
like I like to I really like to tell
stories and you know create narratives
that came the other people can relate to
that'll get them navigate them through
their tough times I can do that through
music I can do that visually from you
know creating a series of film
documentary you know I mean I just want
to continue to use my talents to create
a narrative if they could get people to
did self - is there something in there
maybe it's telling but how what do you
feel like calls upon all your gifts and
is there something you do diversity I be
a father being a mother
Wow yeah really the house upon all of my
gifts mmm
yeah it's a great answer to my best
quality yeah you know I'm working on it
yeah and you know working on no but it's
my best quality it's new you know I
possessed it so that's why that's the
most like that's the most honest display
of discipline I've ever like you know
and because it comes back to you you
know I'm listening this is so crazy
right now
nobody is important enough me duh
wow this isn't you know nobody my wife
nobody is important enough for me not to
get a piece of [ __ ] right nobody that's
who I am right
but I don't do it no more no why because
it's gonna come back somewhere to get me
and it's still a selfish reason cuz I'm
always gonna be selfish I think we're
not doing it is because I'm not being
selfish because it's still selfish
reason because that's who I am and I
don't want that Reposado I want that
[ __ ] to come back and hit me that's why
I don't do it but it's not because I
don't want to do wanna [ __ ] somebody
that's the reason why I don't do it and
you know I learnt the Lords of life I
just learned that's what you saw this is
true but I honestly every of course it
could be selfish me thinking about me
but I just enjoyed the peace that's cool
just realized that's just not who I am I
realized it's just I don't want the
[ __ ] from life I don't want the
universe [ __ ] with me I think we all
right we've all arrived to the same
conclusion but use different paths to
get there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah how
often are you doing the podcast you feel
really stoked about that is that
something you're excited about I feel
like that cause that's its storytelling
we got Pete I don't like to talk to you
man hey listen man it's an honor to be
here III blessed to be able to be a
books you know the ranks of search in
the podcast where y'all send this [ __ ]
off fine yeah we may be going to the
wards to win some of those yeah
[ __ ] right yes it was awesome for you
to have my con expeditiously right oh I
hope I'm lucky enough to be a guest man
now that I actually know you absolutely
it's all good now bestest you know it's
all it takes to do it just to meet me
meet with sadhana have interesting
discussions absolutely you guys come to
your crib hang out when you go what are
they doing over there can you bring
upstairs my to be my girlfriend back in
the day really my girlfriend back in the
day and stuff man that did work out I'm
savage man I'm sure they all do it very
well I think that you know they probably
you know somewhere landing on the back
of money right now yeah she's killing us
she's on another show isn't she noted
she's acting I mean that's just assume
everybody's doing exceptionally well
yeah well he look like
I think I will give them the air on the
side of them doing well yeah Black
Dahlia wise oh they're family
[ __ ] closes the big [ __ ] mansion
like Leo's [ __ ] woman yeah it was a
marsh they looking Lord you'd be looking
good
I guess so man yeah alright brother
yeah it's great to have you in here
better thank you
man I'm sorry Thank You Man yeah really
pretty what what a pleasure it is to
come in here and smoke with you guys you
know and drink doing what do you think
you're doing
it's tasty tasty recepies I think it's
getting me a little tipsy it's a
possible it'll make you it'll chill you
out for sure okay cool yeah really
awesome awesome Fredo even beautiful
some color I can't wait to do Tippin
tysyna Tyson and tip tip entice
everybody will be so [ __ ] jealous
yeah oh yeah copier to go tell you
listen they're gonna try to get an
athlete and a rapper and make them be
partners now they're gonna bite this but
this is organic yes
no that'll be so against go groans good
combos right oh man awesome all right
everybody yes indeed well that's it for
us here at hotbox and thanks for
listening thanks for watching such a
pleasure to smoke with you guys
welcome the happy merger to have you
tips by the time what you wanted where
they can't work and they find you well
at Trouble Man 31 on instagram at TI p
Trouble Man
it's the FEL Twitter and Oh trouble may
now salute later here's a movie in
Marvin Gaye did soundtrack yeah but look
though also as a developer man I'm proud
to say that I'm about to but to break
ground on my first development in
graduation thank you on the west side of
your life what a joke people what it is
yeah absolutely it's a close to a 200
unit multi multi family mixed-use
community with retail and the that's
awesome unity involve things like
after-school programs community gardens
community centers if you need to come on
your grand opening call me man I come at
my wife need to go down as you gather
literally she's trying to get down there
without asking me to go and see her
girlfriends will come absolutely man I'm
doing a small just as this is my first
inkling of what people like you and
Tyler Perry adore yeah just say I'm just
starting a little bit at a time doing a
lot that's what I want you to say say
big things or think big and yeah you
listen oh it's big to me I'm just saying
compare comparison think I've ever do it
to everybody right now it is man if
you're changing a lot of people's lives
- well I appreciate it man I mean having
the opportunity and being afforded the
ability to do so is you're a blessing
within itself it's awesome yeah it's
great
this is like my club right low barking
what's happening because our education
system enslaves us yeah I think it tells
us if we don't get a job that's right
get a nine-to-five so it's gonna want it
no woman's gonna wanna hear nobody's
gonna respect this right don't tell it
to build your own business they took go
to school met these people hire you
that's real yeah I felt like a paper in
there hire you you have a job you have
something I felt like that since I was
in school I felt like you know it was
dedicated confident so you know young
black men especially and nothing ever
showed us how to be entrepreneurs you
know that was all we learned that from
the streets and some white man tell you
hey this is your world you can get
anything you want that's how we know no
black man ever told us that we can do
anything we want you man Munger these
guys can't match you gotta believe it I
know no herd know why they believe me
yes I never heard that have kind of her
to her confidence before oh who told you
that my mentor custom Otto Yeah right oh
sheesh anyone ever tell you that me yeah
i Leah enough they never had to hmm
always I never not alway believed
I mean I just read I used to always
compete with it with me there was nobody
my age early on that had enough vision
to present themselves the way I did you
know that I would I would I would always
hold it upon myself like for instance
with my uncles I see how they were the
first people on Mother's Day I see drive
down with the first double-wide freezer
and refrigerator for my grandmom with a
surprise on Mother's Day so as I grew up
I'm a teenager I wanted by my mama
frigerator one day I want to do stuff
like that like me you know like like I
saw my office do for my mama and like
that was never really nobody around me
that I could kind of relate to cuz I had
until I met all my homeboys when I was
about 15 15 16 that was you know and
plus I was bad as [ __ ] man there's
nothing no parent wanted their kids to
really play with me I'm really not
kidding I'm saying don't wind up wearing
out exactly where I'm like I can't
breathe I was living food outside for me
sneaking food you know I wouldn't put up
with a mom tells her kid like hey listen
I'll get to mix it with the road yeah
that was us my house don't bring that
way my clean that point my whole farm
yeah look at his natty can't wait to
[ __ ] invite us in the house yeah say
we turn hi you need great having you
brother thank you so much for inviting
me out absolutely
go home and sleep today the night with
time with it you all right y'all I'm a
pisser clap another great episode of hot
[ __ ] boxing this is Mike until
next time
love yo T thank you sir
peace
[Music]
[Music]